Alvin Kamara Christopher Milan Darren
Young
and Percy Harris c371619
good morning your honor David chesnow
Richard schoenfield and Drew Finley
who's been admitted for a lot of
teaching on behalf of Mr Kamara good
morning Ross good man with Mr Lamaze is
present with me David Brown with Percy
Harris who's President as well good
morning
good morning
good morning honor Johnson
4134 with Mr Darren Young who is
president all right good morning
all right we're going to start with page
two Mr kimara our the proceedings going
forward for today Jordan we have
received a copy of the indictment
believe it's reading entry not guilty
plea labor writer speedy trial request
probably set in the ordinary course food
activated the July date if that's close
to the ordinary course all right thank
you Mr America's legal name for the
record Alvin
tomorrow uh your attorney has indicated
that you're entering a plea is not
guilty is that correct yes how old are
you 25 27. how far did you get in school
you're rewrite and understand the
English language yes you have a type of
learning disability that affects your
reading comprehension oh yeah
have you recently been treated for any
mental health exceptions
are you currently under the influence of
any drugs medication alcoholic beverage
today
do you understand the proceedings that
are happening yes or no you receive a
copy of the indictment yes ma'am
you wish to wave a formal reading of the
indictment yes
do you understand the service against
you yes sir
you have an opportunity to discuss the
case in the charges of your attorney yes
or no after the charge of one count of
conspiracy to commit battery and first
misdemeanor and one count of battery a
substantial bodily harm a felony how do
you clean deals here not guilty
you have the right for jury trials in 60
days would you like to invoke awake that
right okay
reflect the defendant has ways being
trial rights there's problems that in
the ordinary course the council has
already discussed with the state that
July said it was that pregnancy yes sir
the calendar call July 25th at 9 30.
jury trial July 31st at night your honor
um
is there an earlier day in July 31st
thank you
latest of the June 19th birthday
all right then we'll take I apologize
right we'll take the original thing
page three
three good morning uh Mr Lamaze is ready
to proceed as well he's gonna please
of the indictment
all right thank you I appreciate your
political name for the record tomorrow
okay you're entering a plea of not
guilty
how old are you how far did you get in
school
you read write and understand the
English language yes do you have any
type of learning disability that affects
your reading comprehension have you
recently been treated mental health or
substance abuse issues are you currently
in the influence of any drug medication
or alcoholic beverage this morning you
understand the proceedings that are
happening yes to receive a copy of the
indictment
you wave informal reading of those
charges
felony how do you please guilty or not
guilty
get the right to a jury trial for the 60
days would you like to invoke or waive
that right all right record reflecting
10 has waves being trial rights and
should be set ordinary course
time to call July 25th at 9 30. July
31st at nine
Mr Young page four
yes your honor we have received a copy
of the indictment we have read of you
who reviewed it we would waive the
reading thereof and we would leave the
trial and not feel complete with the
centrality
or currently under the influence of any
drugs medication or alcoholic beverage
this morning
do you understand the proceedings are
happening yes receive a copy of the
indictment
you wave a formal reading of those
charges
excuse me do you waive the formal
reading at this charges
you understand the charts if you have an
opportunity to discuss the charges in
the case of your attorney
as to the charge set forth the
indictment one count conspiracy commit
battery across misdemeanors one count
battery percentage bodily find a felony
how do you plead guilty or not guilty
you have the right to a jury trial for
the 60 days would you like to invoke or
waive that right
reflect the defendant's wave speed trial
rights and shall be set on the same date
as the co-defendants calendar call July
25th at 9 30 jury trial July 31st at 9
. hey Scott Mr Harris
the brown on behalf of Mr Harris we have
received a copy of the indictment will
leave the formal reading he also is
going to raise its right to us we could
try on the internet
please take a full legal name for the
record
I understand English
how old are you 34. how far did you get
in school
thank you you recently been treated
mental health or substance abuse issue
are you currently in the influence of
any drug medication or public beverage
today
you understand the proceedings that are
happening yes you receive a copy of the
indictment
do you waive the formal reading of those
charges yes you understand the target
if you have an opportunity to discuss
the charges in your case with your
attorney
s after the charge that forcing the
indictment felt one conspiracy committed
battery this is first misdemeanor and
count between the batteries containers
bodily harm how do you plead guilty or
not guilty not guilty you have the right
for jury trials in 60 days would you
like to invoke her way that right
record requested Senate has we see crawl
writes and she was set an ordinary
course at the same date as the coaches
calendar call July 25th at 9 30 jury
trial July 31st at night
response
um